[Music]
who needs regular salt and pepper
shakers when you can turn them into a
magical wand kitchen gadgets have come a
long way and we've managed to find some
of the most hilarious items you'll
absolutely need for your kitchen wait
until you see the totally gross egg-yolk
separator give this video a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel
let's check out the 20 crazy kitchen
gadgets you need in your life popcorn
maker let's start off with a bang
literally with a bang
this cannon popcorn maker is one of the
best kitchen gadgets we have ever seen
it's pretty fun too the popcorn shoots
out directly into a bowl as it's powered
by the hot air circulation technology
just plug in the cannon loaded up with
popcorn and you're ready to go the
cannon also comes with an overheat
protection which will keep the popcorn
from flying everywhere except inside the
bowl this definitely looks like it's a
lot of fun and we're adding this popcorn
maker to our Christmas list just
remember to make food not war
microwave s'mores maker if you love
s'mores but are tired of the traditional
way they're made this microwave s'mores
maker is perfect for you not to mention
it's totally adorable it's also a
perfect solution for those who just
can't use a campfire to make s'mores
this s'more maker looks like a robot but
the technology behind it is quite simple
just assemble your s'mores and put the
two heating pads on top the arms will
prevent the marshmallows from
overcooking and your s'mores will be
ready in just 30 seconds oh you need to
do is put water into the reservoir after
each use turn it on and you'll be ready
to go roll and pour got a weak wrist and
can't handle large gallons this
handy-dandy rocking chair helps you
control just how much you pour into a
glass no more spilling drinks sure it
might look way too big to be practical
but we bet there are some of you who
desperately need the Roland pour in your
life if you have small kids who insist
on pouring their own drinks but it
always seems to end up in a mess this
kitchen contraption might be perfect for
you
just place the heavy jug on the gadget
tilt and pour Ally greater okay this one
is just unbelievably cute and we have to
admit that we secretly want it for our
own kitchen it's called the alley grader
and it's totally adorable the jaws fold
backward and allow you to have a sturdy
grip as you grate your favorite cheese
or vegetables then just simply put the
jaws back together and give the ally
grater a well-deserved rest this crazy
grater even has an eye to give a full
impression
of an alligator once you close the jaws
you can clearly see the creatures shape
pretty clever right
oh that it's missing now or some
impressive growling noises pancake pen
who doesn't love making pancakes over
the years they have developed into a
complete art people no longer make
simple circles and eat their pancakes
you can now create stunning portraits
characters lettering and much more all
you need is a pancake pen like this one
and a bit of imagination simply create
your pancake mix fill the pen and you're
ready to go the more you practice the
better your pancake art will become
check out this impressive super mario or
these adorable emojis
what kind of pancake would you want to
draw or are you just too hungry and
don't care either way the pancake pen is
pretty impressive Oreo dipper and if
you're not a fan of pancakes
you probably love Oreos the world's most
famous cookies have been around for a
long time and people are always trying
to invent new flavors that would make
them taste even better with their
popularity the demand for Oreo related
gadgets also increased like this Oreo
dipper perfect for those who like to get
fancy with their cookie dipping
technique simply put your Oreo on the
holder and dip your cookies and milk
these cool dippers even come in
different sets of colors just to make
sure they can match with your kitchen
decor citrus juice sprayer this strange
but innovative gadget is one of our
favorites tired of squeezing lemons just
to get that lemon juice you need to get
yourself one of these crazy kitchen
gadgets the citrus juice sprayer works
on a pretty simple principle just put in
the sprayer in your favorite fruit and
spray away works perfectly on lemons
oranges limes or even fruit like Kiwi
the bottom part of the sprayer is sharp
enough to pierce through the fruit while
the pump is ready to get out all that
delicious juice this one is definitely
on our to buy list and we can't wait to
test it on our salads spaghetti twirling
fork now this is something every
spaghetti lover needs if you have kids
who love spaghetti you know how much
easier your life would be if you didn't
have to teach kids how to twirl
spaghetti using a fork and a spoon this
spaghetti Fork is one of the simplest
but most effective gadgets yet it's
battery-operated which means all you
have to do is push a button and the fork
will start spinning and twirling the
pasta the metal fork is also completely
detachable and safe for any dishwasher
and just like any kid gadget this one
also comes in many different colors
we're pretty sure the twirling fork
would make life easier for any adult
two hotdogs slicers now let's move on to
some of the craziest gadgets ever these
aren't only completely unique in their
functionalities they're also unique in
their design like these hot dog slicers
for example unless you really really
love hot dogs you might not need this
but we bet you can't resist these
adorable wiener dogs this kids food
slicing device is simple to use just
place a hot dog in the wiener dog place
the dog slicer over the hot dog and push
you can also put your favorite sauce in
the bowl before the dog and you're ready
for some yummy sliced hotdogs toothpick
holder this slightly gruesome gadget
might not be for everyone but we bet
there are a few of you who would love to
have this toothpick holder in your own
kitchen
who wants a regular toothpick tool when
you can have something as awesome as
this just imagine you're putting the
toothpicks in someone you hate and it
can be your own personal voodoo doll or
you know you can just use it as a
regular toothpick holder that's just a
bit unique and add some personality to
your kitchen decor thought this one was
crazy wait until you see our last 10
kitchen gadgets Bill Clinton corkscrew
get ready because things are about to
get political when talking about crazy
we can't forget about the Bill Clinton
corkscrew does your kitchen need a bit
of political decor this might be one
gadget you're missing what a perfect
wine accessory and of course the
corkscrew is strategically placed in a
way that will guarantee a laugh every
time you use it
we're pretty sure this dude will
entertain just about every guest in your
home and probably start some awesome
debate just make sure to put it away and
out of children's reach not a Bill
Clinton fan you might prefer our next
option the Hillary Nutcracker these
kitchen gadgets might be crazy but
they're also pretty entertaining we bet
there's someone in your life who would
love to have the Hillary Clinton
Nutcracker in their kitchen even if
they're not a nut kind of person we love
the wording on the box too it's true the
Hillary Nutcracker does have stainless
steel thighs and can probably crack some
of the toughest nuts which one would you
go for the Hillary nut cracker or the
Bill Clinton corkscrew or perhaps you
need both be right back we're adding
this Nutcracker to our Christmas list
check out our next crazy but awesome
kitchen gadget edible jello we're but
enough about political kitchen gadgets
here's something that's completely crazy
but also insanely useful edible jello
air is one of those items you never knew
you needed until now these edible
drinking glasses were first introduced
as part of a competition that encouraged
designers to use gelatin in innovative
ways these glasses are completely edible
so after you take a sip of your drink
you can also taste the delicious agar
agar gel which is flavored with
ingredients like mint basil ginger
rosemary and beetroot you can also throw
this jello where in the grass as agar
agar gel nurtures the growth of plants
delicious and environmentally friendly
at the same time magical salt and pepper
shakers but if you're not into any weird
and gruesome gadgets these might be the
ones for you there are salt and pepper
shakers but instead of being designed
the regular way they've transformed into
magical wands just fill your wands with
salt or pepper and shake them over your
favorite dish and voila it'll magically
taste better the dispensers are made of
food safe plastic and are just the
perfect present for any wannabe wizard
if you like putting that magical touch
into your cooking these salt and pepper
shakers are a perfect solution these
could also be a magical solution for
kids who are just too picky to eat
vegetables and other healthy foods
toaster tree now let's move on to some
of the fanciest items toasters are
becoming pretty advanced but we haven't
seen anything like this unique toaster
tree this tree isn't available for
purchase but it's such a unique design
we're adding it to our list the sleek
design makes it perfect for any
contemporary kitchen just stick the
toast on the leaves and turn on the
toaster the Nano electric membrane
technology will take care of your toast
well the toaster will make your kitchen
look fancy and innovative we really
can't wait to get our hands on one of
these dog and towel holders we have to
admit this one is just too hilarious not
to be included on our list we've seen
plenty of animal shaped gadgets but this
is one of our favorites if your towels
keep on falling off from the regular
handles you might want to try out this
dog and towel holder just stick it on
the wall and it's ready to go put your
favorite kitchen towel in the crack and
just pull it out whenever you need to
this hilarious gadget might raise a few
eyebrows but it's also one of the
funniest things we've ever seen knife
holder if you're sensitive to certain
images you might want to look away
because this is probably one of the most
gruesome kitchen gadgets ever but it's
also pretty entertaining do you need a
unique knife holder it's no longer just
a wooden block where you can stick your
knives knife holders are now turned into
a wooden artwork like this head for
example it's definite
weird but for some reason we also really
want to see it in our kitchen
combined with the toothpick holder we
showed you earlier what do you think is
this a yay or a nay for your shopping
list wine holder speaking of weird you
might want to combine your Bill Clinton
corkscrew with this funny gadget
sometimes your favorite wine just needs
to be kept in a special place so why not
in the lap of this giraffe looks like
it's enjoying it just a little bit too
much you can also get these wine holders
with other animals including an
armadillo a baby kitten or even a fish
but our favorite is this awesome snake
wine holder which makes the whole thing
look that much more terrifying we're
adding this one to our Christmas list to
along with our favorite wine which
animal would you choose for your wine
holder Tic Tac toast and we're on to our
second favorite we've already shown you
a pretty awesome toast maker that's
unfortunately not available for purchase
but instead you can get the Tic Tac
toast which is just as awesome they say
that you can't play with your food but
is there really any harm in putting
peanut butter and jelly on your toast
while playing tic-tac-toe so the process
is simple just press in the Tic Tac
shaped object grab your favorite spread
get a knife and start playing of course
you'll need to have a lot of time during
breakfast but at least your morning will
never be boring again egg-yolk separator
and our favorite out of all the gadgets
we've shown you today is the incredible
egg-yolk separator it's kind of gross
right but at the same time this is one
of the most irresistible gadgets we have
seen and we absolutely have to have it
in our own kitchen
can you imagine baking bread or your
favorite dessert using this strange
gadget show it to your kids and we bet
at least someone will be totally freaked
out by the slimy white egg yolk coming
out of this guy's nose we have to admit
this is one of the most creative kitchen
gadgets ever and that's it for our video
for more videos like this one check out
10 secret apps not on the Google Play
Store see you next time
[Music]